Hi kids. Welcome back. Here's what we're going to do. Step one, we're actually
going to analyze the file name itself and determine what file type it is by
looking at the extension of the file name. This function is going to return an
integer, which represents what type of file it is. For our purposes, we've
defined that 0 should be an image, and type 1 should be a JavaScript file. Now,
as you can see, loading a JavaScript file is very similar to loading an image.
We actually create the object, we set a callback, and then we actually set its
source. Now, there's a couple other things we have to do because we're
injecting script into the DOM, like setting its attribute type and then
actually appending it to the DOM. But other than those two things, it's pretty
similar. The real magic comes down here at the bottom, when we actually analyze
the file name to determine what type it is. So, for example, if it has a .jpg,
we assume it's an image, versus a .js, which we assume is then JavaScript.